to practice filtering queries by
property you're going to add a new
function to the conference API class you
can call the function whatever you like
maybe something like filter playground
the name doesn't matter because this
function isn't going to be called by the
UI you'll be using this function to
experiment with filters you can think of
it as a playground method for exploring
queries this time you can leave off the
at a fee method annotation you don't
have to but it's a good chance to see
what happens if you do the method will
still be exposed as an endpoint function
but it'll use default values for the
published function name the path and the
HTTP method since we won't be using
forum to post values to this method we
don't need to set the HTTP method to
post it will work fine to use the
default HTTP method define the function
to create a query to get all conferences
where the city property has a value
London sort the query results by
conference name run the app on localhost
and use the api's explorer to test it
look for the new function name in the
list of functions I called mine filter
playground and you see it shows up here
as conference doc conference API dot
filter playground you won't be able to
test your new function in the conference
central UI because nothing in the UI
calls your function I want to emphasize
again that you must run the query first
on localhost before you deploy the app
to apps button and run the query there
if you deploy it to appspot first you'll
get an error when you run the query
let's execute it and yes I have some
conferences in London obviously you need
to make sure that you have some
conferences in London or you won't get
any results in this query after you've
got your query to work come back to the
code for your playground method and add
another filter and this time run a
filter to check if the topics includes
medical innovations pay attention to the
fact that the topics property has a
plural its topics and make sure you
spell medical innovations right
the topics property can have multiple
values but you can create a filter for
topics just as you would for a property
with a single value the results will
include applicable conferences whose
topics include the value medical
innovations after you've made the
changes to your code run the app on
localhost and try out the function
the app is Explorer you'll need to make
sure you have some conferences in London
and that the topics includes medical
innovations if you don't get any results
check that you really do have some
conferences that meet all those criteria
oops I don't I'm going to have to go add
another conference the easiest way to
create conferences is to use a create
conference page in the UI so I added
another conference has a very good name
chocolate for health and the topics
includes medical innovations you see
that it's not medical innovations is not
the only topic is just one of the topics
and the city is London
so my filters do work so when you've got
your filters to work go ahead and check
the box yes that they're working